[Musique]
Je ne suis pas vraiment doué pour ce genre de
conneries Wow bon voyage en bas de la
colline mon pote
un deux trois oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
reviens ici je lui ai tiré dessus par erreur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu écoutes quelque chose de cool
oh ouais me donne envie d'être dans un
club de danse seuls les gars ne connaissent pas les filles
qu'est-ce que c'est oh mon dieu c'est tellement énorme
[Musique]
qui est-ce oui maman c'est que toi
c'est sa fille ne fera jamais de porno
grand succès, ils manquent
un détail important
quel est ce talent conduire une voiture ici
aujourd'hui madame ouais oh ne me regardez pas
c'est à propos du sentiment c'est tout à propos
du sentiment que vos parents savent que vous êtes une
[ __ ] de rue maintenant parce que je '  je ne suis pas doux
pucker positif dit mal
[Musique]